- Hi.
- I'm good. I had you, I
had you sit next to me.
- Nice to see you.
- [Kelly] I love everyone.
You're my favorite, obviously.
- Oh, well we've known
each other a long time.
- I know, we've known each other longer.
- Yeah. How many years is it now?
- Oh my God. Almost 20.
- [Simon] Yeah. Must be. Yeah.
- I'm 40.
I'm 40.
- And it feels like yesterday.
- Yeah. I was 19, 20 like when I won.
Yeah, it's crazy.
So wait, did y'all not invite Howie,
'Cause last time he took his shirt off?
Were you embarrassed?
Were you embarrassed of Howie?
Is that why he's not here?
- [Simon] Can I tell you what happened?
- [All] Yeah.
- [Terry] Whoa.
- [Heidi] Howie.
- [Simon] I'll tell you what happened.
- [Kelly] Like what?
- He thought the show taped in New York.
So Howie's in New York today.
- [Heidi] I know.
- [Kelly] Are you serious?
- I swear.
- What kind of things are, is Howie on?
- I don't know, but I called him.
I said, where are you?
And he said, where are you?
And I said, well, I'm at
the "Kelly Clarkson Show."
And he went, "Oh, I thought
it was in New York."
So he's gone to the wrong city. Yeah.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We did open the season in New York.
He's not completely wrong,
we shot the show in New York.
- So he kind of got it right.
- [Kelly] He's just like months off.
- Okay yeah. Okay.
- Well look, we're thinking about him.
- Okay, well, what I'm
thinking about too is like,
we do have a person that goes shirtless
a lot here and he has not.
Exactly, exactly.
- [Terry] You know the thing
is I go shirtless so much,
- [Simon] Look at that.
- [Kelly] Look at this picture!
- [Terry] It's different seeing me suited.
You know what I mean?
- Yes.
So I had to change it up
today and wear a suit though.
- [Kelly] Do you, do you,
you better tell me and lie,
do you just live at a gym?
- Yeah, actually I do, I do. My,
- Do you just love it? Is
it like an endorphins thing?
It's like therapy?
- I can't do without it.
I'm weird without it.
I get in my two hours a
day and it's my peace.
- [Kelly] (singing) Oh my God.
- I call it my spa. It's
my spa time, every day.
- [Heidi] I wish I had that.
- Me too
- I love that
- Everyday, everyday.
- I wish I had that.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
Who's more shirtless,
do you think, Terry,
or your husband, Sofía?
- My husband is not that
shirtless anymore. (laughs)
- [Kelly] He doesn't do shirtless anymore?
- [Terry] Yeah, woohoo!
(audience cheering)
- [Simon] My God!
- He used to when he was doing
True Blood and Magic Mike,
but not anymore.
- [Simon] I feel inadequate right now
- I do complain about it, but.
- [Kelly] You do complain about it?
You're like what happened?
It looks painted on, the both of you.
It looks fake, like, to people
who don't look like that.
- [Sofía] Yeah yeah yeah.
Very good looking guys,
I'm always around, yeah.
- You're like, I only
surround myself with this.
I love this.
So you fell from a bike, like again.
So like what, why do you
keep getting on bikes?
- The assassin, the,
- [Kelly] How are you feeling?
- [Simon] Ever since
Sofía joined the show,
we've all had accidents.
- [Kelly] Wait, is this true?
- Yup.
- I, they say that,
- Well it's true
- But I don't believe it
because nothing has happened to me
- [Simon] One by one,
- I haven't even in
two years gotten COVID,
not even once, so I don't know.
- [Kelly] Oh, you, girl,
you better be knocking
on that wood right now.
I'm knocking for you.
- Wait, so what?
- I dunno why he blames me for everything.
- [Simon] I, I'm just saying.
- [Kelly] Wait, so what happened to y'all?
Did something happen to y'all?
- Well, one by one we've all had accidents
ever since Sofía joined the show.
Howie's not here.
- [Heidi] Well it is kind of true.
When Sofía came the first year,
we met, the next day I was sick.
- [Sofía] She was sick.
- [Simon] Oh, I was ill,
then I broke my back.
- They say that I was trying to judge
the whole show by myself, but.
- And host!
- She's the only one left at the table.
- Yeah.
- Oh my gosh. I love, I
don't think that you're,
you're a bad Juju, I
think you're great Juju.
Well, we're all parents.
So I think it's important.
I, I learned in therapy,
it's important to show your vulnerability.
I've had like a rough
two years and it's hard,
sometimes, if you get sick
or if something happens
or whatever, to show you're
kind of vulnerable to your kids,
but it's actually really
important that we do that.
- [All] Yep.
- Are y'all good at that?
- I mean, when I have cried,
my, they look at me like,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You crying?
There's tears coming
out of those eyeballs?
Because they're not
used to that because you
always try to hold it
in or hold it together.
- [Kelly] Me too!
- [Simon] Yeah.
- But then when it goes, they're like,
they can't believe it,
and they stare at you.
Like, who are you?
- I did, I held back,
'cause I was like, well,
I don't want them to like,
I know they're gonna end up
for therapy for something,
but I didn't want that to be the thing.
So I was, I tried not to.
My therapist was like, it's okay to be sad
in front of your kids or get
hurt or not be invincible.
And that was really hard for me.
Are you good at letting your guard down?
- No, I was really, really bad.
And also like, I was a single mother,
'cause I divorced when
he was one year old.
So I felt like I needed
to be the strong father
and the mother at the same
time and I am a Latin woman.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So I was kind of, if I could go back,
I would be different, I
would be, you know, more,
I can't say that word, vulnerable.
- [Kelly] Vulnerable?
(all laughing)
- Yeah vulnerable, vulnerable, that's it.
- If I could go back,
I would learn English
before coming to the United States.
- Oh my God, that question was worth it
just for that moment.
- Yeah. It's like I would,
- Try a ventriloquist.
- I would be different, but
you know, it is what it is.
You do your best.
I think being a parent,
you can't be perfect.
You just have to try to do your best.
- [Heidi] Yeah!
- [Kelly] No, it's
interesting though, too,
because I'm Southern, a
Texas woman, and we're,
I don't know if that's similar
to like the Latin culture,
- [Sofía] Yes.
- [Heidi] I'm a German
woman, and we are too
- but it's like, I'm a mama
bear and single mom as well.
So it's like you, I was like,
wait, are you not supposed to?
Yeah, exactly.
- [Heidi And Sofía] Yeah.
- [Kelly] We're very strong women.
Y'all like to be
surrounded by strong women.
I like it, I like it.
So last time Howie was
on, he was showing you
how he could walk in your heels.
- Yeah.
- Is that real or did he just do it
just for that video and then fell?
- Honestly, I think he's
training a lot at home.
He's getting really good.
He's getting much better.
(all laughing)
- [Terry] Oh, oh
- [Sofía] I remember this, I remember.
- [Heidi] He's getting better.
- [Kelly] How he moves
his thighs is so amazing.
- [Sofía] How did he do that?
- I mean he was okay then,
but he's really good now.
So I know, Howie, you've been training,
wherever you are in New York.
- [Simon] Can you imagine
what it must be like
living with Howie?
- I mean crazy.
- I mean seriously.
- Crazy!
- I mean, this goes on
every day in his household.
- [Kelly] Somebody may be medicated.
- [Sofía] You know he's
living it because you see it
on his phone, on his TikTok.
- [Simon] Yeah.
- [Terry] Yeah.
- It's like, that's how he lives.
- [Heidi] Yeah.
- Oh my goodness. His TikTok is crazy.
- [Kelly] Look at all of you,
you're all like scared in your eyes.
- Yes. His TikTok is nuts.
- More like traumatized, yeah.
- Wait, so speaking of
fashion, 'cause obviously,
that was fashionable, you have an eye
when it comes to suits, you
always look so sharp, Terry.
So do you, do you have a favorite look?
- First of all, I have a guy.
- [Kelly] Look at this one.
- [Sofía] You should have worn that today!
- [Terry] Oh my God. Yeah, I know!
- What happened?
- I know. Where was this suit today?
- I have a guy who makes everything,
to the shoes, to all this stuff.
He's so important to me, I
can't divorce him, like he's
absolutely more important
than anything in my life.
- Never say never.
- I'm like, "I need you man.
I can't quit you, okay?"
So he can get anything he wants.
He's like Terry, whatever.
I'm like, "Man, I love you."
He makes everything.
- So you don't even have
to do fittings anymore,
he knows your size, everything, just?
- No!
- Terry, what's his name?
- Can you imagine? I'm sorry?
- What's his name?
- His name is Nana Boateng.
- [Simon] All right, we gotta plug him.
- And he is absolutely
the best in the world.
- And you're not afraid of color.
- Do you, is it because
you have to have suits made
because of your body?
- Yeah, I can't buy anything off the rack.
It would be sitting there
like, "Hey, how y'all doing?
What's up? Hey!"
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- Nothing off the rack
for me, it has to be made.
And it's amazing.
- [Kelly] It's so, you
know what's funny is,
on The Voice, John does that.
John Legend always has, he's, I'm like,
"How do you look that sharp all the time?"
- Ahem, don't mention that show.
(laughter and applause)
- Oh, sorry, Oh sorry. Sorry.
- Don't mention it.
- Every time, so I gotta reword it,
So every time I work with
John, I'm always like, oh man,
he's so nice. He always
looks so nice in his suits.
And he gets them made, his shoes
as well, he's like into it.
- Oh my God. What?
- [Kelly] He takes more
time than I do, probably.
- [Terry] Yeah. I know.
- Which the bar is low.
But yeah, he's really into it as well.
I know a lot of men are
like way more into fashion
than women I know.
- [Terry] But see, we could
take care of ourselves now.
- [Simon] Oh, I'm obsessed with it
- You are?
- Oh, look at me.
- I was like your black
shirts, and your...
I was gonna go for the
joke, but you did first.
- Oh, no, no, trust me.
It's like, what are you
gonna wear next week?
It's like, the same.
- [Kelly] The Johnny Cash black.
- I just have one outfit.
- [Kelly] You know what? It's nice.
- It's easy.
- You don't have to think about it.
- Exactly.
- Exactly. I look the same
unless Candace is styling me.
I'm with you, jeans, tee shirt.
- Meanwhile, Heidi and I,
when we have to repeat clothes
because of the auditions,
we don't like it.
- Again!
- We're like, we don't
wanna work anymore here,
wearing the same outfit
for two days in a row.
- I think this is the hardest for us,
because sometimes we are like,
five days in the same look,
and honestly the outfit
can walk by itself.
We're always talking to one another.
We're like, "Again, the same outfit!"
- You hate it.
- [Kelly] That's actually
happened to me on a show!
You have to wear it for
like five days in a row.
And it's like, you have
to be very specific
about what you're wearing,
because especially
if it's stretchy at all,
like elasticity wears.
And so like by day five...
- It's a complete different dress,
that happens to me all the time.
I sit down for three days,
and then it's like, "What is this?"
It's like, "Oh no, now you
have to do the red carpet."
I'm like, I just can't, I can't.
- [Kelly] No, and it stretches as well.
It's like, especially if,
if it's like a jumpsuit,
I did a jumpsuit one time and I was like,
how is this elongated, like it's longer?
And I'm so short, we
just cut the bottom line.
Yeah, it's really hard.
- All of a sudden, it's a drop-crotch.
- Yeah, I'm just all of a sudden,
which is not attractive
on a person that's 5'3".
- [Simon] We could have uniforms.
- Yeah, you just look shorter.
No, we don't want uniforms.
- Look what he's saying,
that we should wear uniforms.
- [Simon] Yes, it's easy!
- [Terry] AGT uniforms.
- No, no, no.
- Honestly, I am actually
gonna side with Simon on this
'cause it'd be way easier.
- You might like them.
- A nice AGT uniform.
You wear "A", I wear "G", you wear "T".
- [Simon] Yes, yes!
- [Sofia] No!
- Heidi, at least we can
swap our uniforms, at least.
- Just let us do it for one day, please.
- [Kelly] It will not, look
at her face. She just said no.
- Only if you let me
dress you for one day.
- [Simon] Okay, done, deal.
- [Kelly] (gasps) Oh my God.
- You have to keep this promise.
- Why are you agreeing without my consent?
- [Heidi] We'll do it together,
we go shopping together.
We hook him up with a new outfit.
- Oh, okay, that's what that was.
- Yeah, you get to dress him
and he gets to dress y'all.
This should be interesting.
- I thought it was like a uniform.
- This one right here!
- What are you gonna wear?
You have to do something,
this is not just a bet
that you get scot-free.
- I'm going shirtless,
I'm going shirtless.
- [Sofia] Yeah, so that
you can go with everything.
- [Kelly] That's where we all win.
- It always matches.
Everything matches with shirtless.
- Everyone wins, everything wins.
So who takes the longest
in hair and makeup?
(Simon clears his throat)
- [Terry] Ooh.
- Oh, nobody even thought about it.
- [Simon] Oh, come on.
- To be honest, to be
honest, we never stop.
- Well, we never stop.
But the thing is that there's
always something happens
to me because I am Latin, it is true.
I always wake up on-time.
It's not that I'm sleeping or anything.
I wake up on time, but
something always happens
and I'm always not in the
perfect, perfect time.
She, you are always in the perfect time.
- I think it's because you wear one lens
and not in the other,
so you're always like...
- I don't know, but there's
always something or I fall down
- It's because of one lens!
- Or I can't find the eyeliner,
or the dog is doing something
it's not supposed to do,
oh, there's always some drama in my house.
- [Simon] So basically,
the answer is Sofía.
- So let's talk about the
new season of the show.
So Simon, what act on America's Got Talent
has scared you the most,
of all the seasons?
- Ooh. Oh, I know.
- Two.
- Okay.
- Two people went up a
very, very, very high pole.
- [Terry] Oh!
- I mean, it, it's difficult to describe,
but it was very scary
and it nearly went wrong,
and it was a father and a daughter,
and they're like 300
feet, 400 feet in the air.
One of then's blindfolded,
and then she got nervous.
- Did something happen to the dad? Or no?
- [Simon] It was just, it, it
nearly went horribly wrong.
So it was terrifying, and in fact,
I asked them the question
because they were so high up,
I said, what, what happened?
And basically she lost
her nerve at the top,
and she's talking to her dad
and her dad's basically saying,
"Look, maybe we shouldn't do this."
So it was terrifying.
And the second most terrifying was a girl
who was 10 years old.
- Yes.
- I won't give it away, but I thought
she was very sweet until
she started to sing.
And it, and I actually
called for a priest.
- [Kelly] It was like the Exorcist?
- [Simon] It was like the Exorcist.
- Was she into like heavy metal?
- It was crazy.
- It was, I'll actually send you the clip,
because I, that was my
expression, I'm like, what?
And I asked her,
"Have you ever seen a
movie called the Exorcist?"
And she just stared at me.
And I said, I'm not asking anything else.
- She's got a voodoo doll.
- I also love Jack the Whipper.
- Oh my God.
- You did you say "Jack The Whipper?"
- Yeah, because Simon,
there's this guy with a whip,
- That sounds like an S&M kinda, like.
- But, Simon was nice
enough to go onto the stage
where we kind of made him.
- You pushed me.
- We pushed you.
He had a stick in between his legs.
He's standing there and a
skiing downhill position,
and he's whipping in between
his legs, this little stick.
And you know that could've
gone awfully wrong.
- [Sofía] But why, it was so funny?
We don't understand why it was so funny.
We were down there on
the desk, like, dying.
- Oh, they were loving it.
- That's 'cause your body
parts aren't about to go down.
- [Simon] Yeah, they
were laughing so much.
I nearly have my what's-its whipped off,
and they're in hysterical laughter.
- I got five wrinkles more that day
because we were laughing so hard.
- [Kelly] Oh my God,
that's a lot of trust.
I don't love, I was never good at like,
the trust fall scenario,
you know when they do it?
- I got my revenge, don't
worry, later on that night.
- I had an apple shot off my head before
with a bow and arrow, that was crazy, too.
- [Kelly] Do you have to
sign some kind of waiver?
Like I'm like, this seems...
- No, no, but this is the funny thing.
The producers are the ones
screaming at us to go up.
So we've had knives
thrown at us, as you said,
bolts, you know, what was it?
- Like a bow and arrow.
- [Simon] Bow and arrow.
- [Kelly] I saw that.
- Whipping, I mean, and
it's like, thanks a lot.
- Do the producers like y'all?
- [Heidi] You guys think
this judging stuff is easy.
It's dangerous!
- [Simon] It's very scary.
- [Kelly] I know, I'm just saying somebody
could shout that out to
me and I'd be like, nope.
- [Sofía] I thought I
was not gonna make it
yesterday, actually.
- [Heidi] Yeah. It's true.
- I thought, but you know, I
look at his face and you think,
"Okay, he's the boss,
so his face, he knows,
and there's no not danger."
And I look at his face and
he's looking at me like...
I was like, wait, wait!
- [Terry] She had whips
going all around her,
- [Kelly] What're you, like,
Indiana Jones on your show?
- Yeah.
- And you know, they get kind of nervous.
So whatever they prepared, it
can go wrong, Kelly, you know?
- [Sofía] But wait, what happened was also
that in the middle of his
thing, he decides to put the.
- [Heidi] The buzzer!
- [Terry] Oh, and he shakes
the guy up, he's like, oh.
- [Sofía] When you're next
to the guy, you can feel
the guy's energy changing,
so I'm looking at him,
I'm like, "How do I get outta here now?"
Because I see him like immediately, like.
- [Terry] He did it, he was like, oh.
- But when he hears that horrible sound,
you can't do that anymore.
- [Heidi] Because they get scared,
and then things can go wrong.
- I wasn't thinking, I apologize.
- [Terry] Oh, he lost
all his concentration.
He was whipping like, oh wow.
- Wasn't thinking, slash,
what would happen now?
- We were like oh, whoa!
- [Kelly] Terry, you have a new memoir.
So did your family help
you at all with it?
- Yes they did because
they're in it, like big-time.
- [Kelly] Okay. Did you have?
- And again, my kids were
like, oh my God, you told 'em
about this, you told 'em about that.
But first of all, I love the fact,
I really like being transparent
because most men don't talk.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We just don't talk to each other.
And I said, man, we've got to be,
I wanted to make sure people
didn't feel alone, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And especially the guys and
we talk about our own issues,
the things we're going
through and just open up
these conversations and it's so cathartic,
and it felt so good.
I think everybody in the world
needs to write their own book so you can
straighten out your values,
know where you stand.
And it was just so much fun.
- [Simon] By the way,
I'm not just saying this.
I have started to read
it, it is brilliant.
You've got to buy this book
and I really mean this.
I'm not just saying this
'cause I was told to.
- I love that you did it
with your family though,
because that's kind of
true and they'll keep you,
'cause sometimes I feel like your friends
or your family almost know you
better than you do sometimes.
- [Terry] Yeah.
- Even if you're like the
most self-aware person.
So that's really cool.
- [Terry] Yeah.
- And also a chance for them to be like,
"No, that's not going in there."
- Exactly, well, my wife will tell me,
"No, that didn't happen.
You need to straighten
that chapter out right now."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm like, okay.
- [Kelly] Here's what I said.
And here's how amazing I was.
(all laughing)